from great suffering came a solution
communities
injected serene beautiful places where
disorder became
harmony do you know how to fly though
absolutely do you get to fly to the edge
oh yeah what's best there don't know
we're not allowed to fly past that let's
go it's against the rules jonas
they're called books
hello
my name i know who you are
who are you the giver when the elders
need guidance i provide wisdom using
memories of the past our world was
different there was more
what
much
more right you'll see them all in time
all colors all differences
our people chose to do away with
emotions those morning injections take
them away
when people have the freedom to choose
to choose wrong tomorrow morning skip
your injection i've been doing it for
months
what do you feel he's not usually like
this i'm surprised you're not more
worried about him i would be bring up
jonas's activity
he's inquisitive you should know better
than anyone the way things look and the
way things are are very different
what that's my father there is no way
for me to prepare you from the truth
he killed him the young and the older
killed for the good of all of us
there are things you don't know you're
scaring me go back to your family unit
it isn't my family and neither is yours
jonas has become dangerous
i know that there's something more
something that has been stolen
comfortable
jealous there has to be a way to show
them you can stop this
you can change things
i want you to find him
and then i want you to lose him
you